Oh
[Music]
my name is Danny McBride I play
Tennessee in the film I do wear a cowboy
hat and I'm Sigourney Weaver what was it
like - um - what - I Ripley I get it a
lot it was incredible it was
groundbreaking yeah that a lot yeah you
you know playing a strong female lead is
something that's kind of always come
naturally to me well that make sense
yeah it's not for anything I've
struggled with so it's good to be able
to find a project to put it to use right
no is he gone
yeah you know this role I think that he
this character Tennessee doesn't I think
take things as seriously as some of
these other characters do but what's
cool about this script is that it just
gets going right out of the gate
something very tragic happens and so
you're meeting these people under a lot
of stress and under a lot of the unknown
so you don't really get to meet these
characters when they're relaxed they're
just shooting the breeze yeah yeah yeah
Jake asked me to say something that's
okay
please
it's really fun so much people 26 out of
wait us of course I'm not gonna ask if
there's any connection to Ripley but is
there any way baby
I am Ripley's dad yeah and you're sold
it right there obviously yeah rippers
cousin yeah um yeah no I I heard that
rumor too that's all I know about it I
[Music]
mean it seems so obvious but it looks
like an alien movie when you get on set
you know and I think we were all kind of
looking around at each other you believe
physically like it feels like you're in
a museum for the original alien moving
to get on set and all the controls and
you know we all have to act like we know
what they do and um figuring all that
out everything was really exciting but
that's it all comes from Ridley's minds
and he knows everything about every
aspect of what's on that set like in the
Covenant spaceship I would just be like
kind of playing around with the touch
pad or whatever and he would have a
whole design of why exactly that was
there and how that technology is
something that NASA is using or or that
we'll be using and so it's almost just
like a big science lesson the whole time
presents it to you're like learning
about where things are going and you
know designs and yeah it was pretty
incredible and the fact that all of its
built is awesome to it so you're not
really running around in front of a
green screen it's like at one point
we're in a spaceship that you come to
the set and they really have it on a
gimbal that's making the spaceship go
like 50 feet up in the air and come down
again and it's like you're getting to
ride an amusement park ride all day it's
crazy
[Music]
yeah The Creature Shop was incredible I
would go walk around there all the time
and just all the designs the creatures
and then when you see just like
castmates
just dead in the Creature Shop I I can't
tell you who it was but there was one
cast mate that I went to their dead
replicas and just took a bunch of
selfies in front of it just kind of
desecrating ya corpse here's one down I
looked out on my trailer and there was a
guy just walking by with my friend's
head really bizarre